raheem barton
posted so-called drill videos online and
was one of two people in this film from
the gang moscow 17 who was killed
last year he's rapping about something
called the scoreboard
which we understand is a violent point
system
there's a virtual scoreboard and people
are keeping
the account of the the attacks that each
organization and in terms of gang
organization that they're carrying out
if you stab a person in the head or
the chest or whatever maybe you get
varying points for the severity of the
the violent act
and again that is making it a game
and taking somebody out and killing
somebody is now fun
stace holmes lewis runs a mentoring
program for young people in gangs here
on the brandon estate in south london
where raheem was killed
this photo of seis and raheem was taken
on the day he was murdered
almost immediately afterwards a rival
gang was bragging about the murder on
social media
inflaming tensions i saw the videos
bragging about raheem's death and
the instagram accounts and some of the
snapchat and like it it was sickening
and it made me obviously severely upset
and
if you were younger more influential
you'd be thinking right i'm going to get
response because that's the natural
inclinations that you want to
protect your own we understand this is
how the scoreboard works
50 points for a wound to the head 30 for
the chest
20 for the stomach 10 for a leg and 5
for an arm
it's the scoreboard raheem sings about
before he's killed
chris predi who works with young people
in gangs interprets the song so
basically it's just narrowing off saying
within this understanding is the
scoreboard
he's talking about stabbing people the
people that he is stabbing and the gangs
that he's he's facing against right now
so
the terminologies that they're using
when they're talking about chinging and
and questing
it means taking out a knife it means
swinging a knife around it means that
he's really really on job
on job means he really really does what
he says that he does and he's basically
right now talking about stabbing other
people which they call ops but
is a copper um a co-host name for
opposition
[Music]
so he said jk went went prison because
he splashed him so basically he's even
admitting saying that one of my friends
went to prison because he stabbed
someone so they even letting them know
that
you know we really really do this and we
don't mind going in prison for either
my people riding dirty never riding
clean my boss is going
number 23. gang members in ipswich in
this video are singing about scoring
points against a rival gang
four of them were sentenced to life for
murder last month
23 year old aristotle yang 17 year old
kairis davis
19 year old isaac culver and adebayo
amusa who's masked in this video they
stabbed tavis spencer aitkins 15
times and hit him over the head with a
glass bottle
tavis is in this rival gang video
wearing a white t-shirt
in such a small town two gangs can't
co-exist for long without trouble
it's so condensed that there is nowhere
for anybody to escape
yeah and this is when it comes and they
can't hide from each other from each
other
so we get to this stage of now you're
now living your life constantly
constantly on the go constantly ready
for attack
constantly ready to do something and the
worst thing about it deep down in your
heart a lot of the young people deep
down
in their heart don't want to do half of
the things that they're doing i'm
telling you and a lot of times everyone
will sit there and be like no but chris
look at them and they're talking about
in their thing
come on some of these kids are 12 30 and
i talk to them they still watch cartoon
network
like you know what i mean like they
still got like a single bed and power
ranger shoots
like this is reality like this is the
truth they've been playing computer
games call of duty one of warfare and
all this
um stuff that these kids have been
playing and they think and have now
taught that
actual understanding life is a game
where your score points
i'm killing people
these videos are not being taken down
quick enough and they should be
be screened before they go on and i know
it's very difficult with a high volume
of
of traffic on social media but these are
young people
and people are dying as a result of some
of these these things that have been
released on youtube
on instagram and snapchat police say
they are working with social media
companies to try and deal with the
problem
um it is undoubted that social media is
used
uh in order to agitate and to incite
violence
if we would see something like scoring
obviously we would seek to
see those platforms take those websites
down as quickly
as we can we talk about senseless
violence and this is the worst of it
britain's knife crime epidemic is being
fueled by mindless posturing
and a childish point scoring game jason
farrell sky news